bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission de
france ont joué ce week-end le 5ème tour
de la compétition le petit poucet
maurepas n'a pas réussi à créer
l'exploit contre boulogne billancourt
l'équipe qui évolue en cfa tous les
détails sur cette rencontre à suivre
dans cette édition football féminin
montigny-le-bretonneux s'est imposé ce
week-end à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
mende sur le score de trois buts à zéro
en dh des minimes antenne totalise
quatre victoires en cinq matches
disputés nous recevrons dans quelques
instants les joueuses melanie ville
mercati et anaïs gastou ainsi que le
président de montigny olivier biancucci
basket thomis et gore un basketteur ini
montant de 19 ans licencié au club de
versailles pourrait devenir dans les
prochaines années le nouveau tony parker
il vient d'être sélectionné pour
intégrer pendant un an l'université de
cleveland son portrait dans cette
édition
et puis enfin la démission vous
entendrez le pistard de l'équipe de
france françois pervis il reviendra sur
la compétition qui démarre cette semaine
les championnats d'europe sur piste
l' aventure s'arrête au 5e tour de la
coupe de france pour mort pas les
yvelinois qui évoluent en district se
sont inclinés sur leur pelouse du bout
des clos contre boulogne billancourt une
équipe de cfa la logique a donc été
respectée pour celle de ce 5e tour de la
coupe de france malgré malgré une
ambiance sulfureuse
les images ont signé à florac parfait la
magie de la coupe de france n'a pas
opéré au stade du bout des clous pour ce
5e tour les verts de maurepas qui évolue
en division de district n'ont pas réussi
à faire tomber dans leur antre l'ogre de
cfa boulogne billancourt en première
période est mort patients pourtant tenu
en échec les jours des hauts-de-seine et
deux équipes sont rentrées aux
vestiaires dos à dos 1 but partout
en deuxième période des événements
finalement baissé le pied physiquement
résultat final 4-1 pour boulogne
billancourt
on savait avant le match que ça serait
ça sera compliqué je pense que sur ce
match on a tout donné on n'a pas de
regrets à avoir
voilà on sait on s'est donné à 100 %
tout le monde est sorti reims est
vraiment même dans les vestiaires alors
continuez à suffoquer un peu mais je
pense qu'on a tout donné on a fait une
super première mi temps on arrive à
revenir au score et en deuxième mi temps
on a on a payé un peu l'aspect physique
qui je pense a fait la différence
aujourd'hui on n'est pas tombé dans le
piège
de ce tour avec l'équipe
hiérarchiquement en dessous mais avec la
volonté que nous a donné pas mal de fil
à retorde donc voila c'était difficile
allez la chercher mais voilà on a su
être patient est déroulé en deuxième mi
temps pour que la fête soit mémorable
plus d'une centaine de supporters aux
couleurs de maurepas étaient présents au
stade pour encourager leurs protégés
on s'est motivé pour l'occasion vue
qu'ont joué une équipe est très forte en
cfa on s'est motivé pour l'occasion on a
créé tout ça le club nous a aidés à
investir dans tout le matériel prêt à
acheter
on a été très bons on encourager notre
équipe jusqu'au bout et aller là il se
mord pas je pense que ce match là où
elle restera restera mémorable pour tous
que ce soit au niveau du terrain
au niveau du public on a eu un soutien
phénoménal aujourd'hui donc franchement
mémorable
enfin je pense que personne ici pour
oublier ce match là et on espère
réitérer l'exploit l'année prochaine
clap de fin pour cette épopée mort pas
yens rendez vous l'année prochaine pour
de nouvelles émotions et supporters ne
demande qu'à vibrer comme vous avez pu
le voir les y avait une sacrée ambiance
à maurepas les tifosi ont même effectué
un chant à la gloire de tv fils pendant
le match
toujours en coupe de france dans les
autres rencontres de ce 5e tour le bilan
est positif pour les club yvelinois
versailles club de dh est allé s'imposer
sur le terrain de vincennes menthe club
de cfa s'est logiquement imposé sur le
terrain donnait équipe de dsr sur le
score de 4 buts à 0
voici poursuit également sa route sur le
terrain de morangis grâce à sa belle
victoire 3 buts à 0
château a remporté son duel lors du
derby contre rueil malmaison les
événements longtemps porté sur la plus
petite des marges 1 but à 0 enfin oui
axel au 6e tour avec une belle victoire
contre la parisienne 4 buts à 0
du côté des éliminations en plus de
maurepas deux autres clubs ne
connaîtront pas la saveur d'un sixième
tour de coupe de france neauphle équipe
de dsr s'est logiquement incliné contre
drancy club de cfa 2 à 0 et les mureaux
ont perdu en prolongation sur le terrain
d'argenteuil
au total il y aura donc les cinq équipes
évinoise au prochain tour après cette
page coupe de france on passe maintenant
en football féminin
montigny-le-bretonneux s'est imposé ce
week-end à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
menthe sur le score de trois buts à zéro
en dh les zizis lésigny monteyne
totalise à présent quatre victoires en
cinq matches disputés pour nous parler
de cette très bonne dynamique nous
recevons sur ce plateau deux joueuses de
montigny mélanie ville mercati et anaïs
gastaud ainsi que le président olivier
bien cucchi bonsoir on sent alors
olivier qu'est ce qui explique ces très
bons résultats en ce début de saison moi
par rapport à ce début de saison c'est
surtout la cohésion du groupe qu'a
réussi à être mises en place c'est une
équipe très jeune mais avec un très bon
état d'esprit et puis chacune des filles
se bat pour l'autre donc c'est ça qui
nous amène ce très très bon début de
saison sur le papier pourtant tous les
éléments sont pas réunies quand même ses
débuts de saison sont pareilles on a
changé
d'ailleurs willy va également changer
c'est sûr qu'on a une période compliquée
on a beaucoup de joueuses de partie mais
on a quand même un bon noyau qu'à rester
avec mélanie la capitaine anaïs donc et
en plus on a eu des très peu de très
bonnes choses qui sont arrivées aussi
qu'ils sont jeunes certes mais c'est
surtout la cohésion du groupe qui fait
que cette annonce de très très bons
résultats et parlez nous du nouvel
entraîneur cantilien d'entraîneur nouvel
entraîneur il est à peine assez voilà
vient tout juste d'arriver
donc c'est une femme c'est valérie
mercier qui a déjà entraîné au paris
saint-germain donc qui est aussi diplômé
donc c'est une personne qui connaît très
bien le football féminin jusqu'à présent
était vraiment sur les équipes de jeunes
les u16 et des u19 et puis maintenant à
sa progression normale fait que récupère
l'équipe senior mais la nuit vous
comment vous l'expliquez ce début de
saison
je pense que notre plus grande force
notre solidarité malgré qu beaucoup de
départs bas on arrive à garder un noyau
et à recréer un noyau en fait qui est
ultra solidaire et on est super combatif
en fait dans les matchs ça qui nous
permet d'avoir des bons résultats de
rien lâcher jusqu'au bout et vous de
votre côté ce changement d'entraîneur ça
vous a pas perturbé plus que ça
ben moi je sais que valérie je l'avais
eue au psg auparavant quand je le
connaissais déjà et
non non non ont fait mais là avant tout
pour jouer nous-mêmes enfin l'entraîneur
après c'est une chose mais on est là
pour faire gagner l'équipe et fait tout
pour quoi et anaïs justement vous
recevez par an en boulet de canon vous
vous l'attendiez quand vous avez
commencé la saison vous ai dit c'est bon
on va réussir à faire une grande saison
où finalement on va voir on va voir
fille au fur et à mesure des matches
honnêtement non mais beaucoup de filles
sont arrivées des jeunes surtout qui se
donnent vraiment à fond à l'entraînement
quand et même mon match elle se donne
pour tout le monde nous aussi en semaine
pour elles et ils de bons résultats qui
vont continuer par la suite je pense
et qu'est ce qui fait la force de cette
équipe mélanie où le ca ou vous sentez
que que cette équipe a un grand coeur
c'est ça il a travaillé si l'esprit de
groupe
l'esprit de combativité la solidarité
c'est vraiment les deux grosses forces
qui peuvent nous caractérise et je pense
parce que au delà du fait que pas
peut-être qu'en soit moins forte
individuellement que certaines équipes
mais c'est collectivement on arrive à
développer de bonnes phases de jeu de
bon de bonnes choses et ça je pense que
c'est positif pour la suite du
championnat russe
on l'a vu aussi vous marquer beaucoup de
buts en ce faisant j'ai fait trois
matches et de marquer trois buts avec on
va dire beaucoup de chance que c'est pas
du tout mon poste au départ mais j'ai de
la réussite
et tant mieux donc j'espère pouvoir me
libérer je fais un appel à mon patron
sinon je travaille les samedis
après-midi d'accord et comment expliquez
vous justement cette attaque qui marche
plutôt bien finalement il ya une bonne
une bonne ambiance au niveau des
attaquantes
non non on a changé le bonne cohésion en
attaque en tout cas la chine et le
système de jeu est en fait on à réussir
est qu'on arrive bien à se trouver dans
la profondeur ainsi que dans les pieds
donc j'espère que ça va continuer par la
suite même si je vole yviers c'est la
force de montigny cette saison à l'attak
oui enfin l' attaque la défense aussi
parce que si on met quatre buts mais
qu'on en prend cinq
enfin dimanche dernier après on en a mis
trois mais si on en prend 4 ça sert à
rien donc c'est vraiment la taxe pour
moi l'équipe c'est pas que la traque
c'est vrai que l'ac thann ont une bonne
attaque mais on a aussi une très très
bonne défense on a un super bloc
défensif et même les attaquants
défendent
mélanie la première à défendre et
ensuite après il ya le milieu de terrain
et défenseur qui suivra donc c'est
vraiment le noyau quoi ces voix là on
est en pleine reconstruction
mais c'est une équipe très jeune qui
arrive à travailler ensemble et qui je
pense sont des belles années des audits
l'équipe est en reconstruction l'équipe
est assez jeune est ce qu'il y a quand
même des joueuses qui tirent les autres
vers le haut niveau de l'expérience il
ya toujours les mecs dans ces matches on
en a on a quatre cinq filles qui sont
au-delà des 25 ans après mélanie qui est
capitaine a quand même que 20 ans malade
et quand même capitaine donc c'est quand
même une jeune joueuse mais c'est une
c'est une fille qui a déjà un petit peu
d'expérience a déjoué au paris
saint-germain donc
la moyenne d'âge cette année à doit être
à 20 ans à savoir qu'on a qu'une fille
de 30 ans quoi donc c'est une très bonne
chose pour le club puisque la
reconstruction on va partir sur
plusieurs années mélanie justement votre
nouveau rôle de capitaine c'est aussi de
créer cette ambiance entre les jeunes et
les moins jeunes dans l'équipe mais je
veux dire enfin moi je pense pas avoir
joué un grand rôle là dedans parce que
ça s'est fait assez naturellement que
c'est vrai que par rapport aux
différentes années que j'ai pu j'ai pu
être à montigné en fait c'est vrai que
cette année est vraiment une cohésion
enfin n'y a pas de clans dans l'équipe
tout le monde s'entend bien tous une
rigole bien jeunes anciennes et
nouvelles arrivées au club ancienne
joueuse
y'a vraiment pas même la concurrence et
une concurrence saine en fait qui a dans
l'équipe et je pense que c'est ça aussi
qui fait que l'on arrive à progresser en
soule d'accord avec avec votre capitaine
totalement ça fait dix ans que je suis à
montigny et c'est là honnêtement c'est
une des premières années où je vois
autant d'entendre dans l'équipe
finalement c'est peut-être qui fait la
force de l'équipe cette année je pense
je pense que c'est ça qui va faire qu'on
peut être deux pour monter en d2
président quels sont les objectifs du
club cette saison
bah déjà c'est la ccc 2
c'était pas prévu du coût du tout cette
saison les environs on prend tout ce qui
vient donc puis bon le mérite leur
revient et moi moi je fais en sorte en
sorte de leur montée de leur montrer mon
soutien du mieux possible
j'espère j'espère que j'y arrive donc
leur montrer que le club est derrière
rennes l'objectif sur une reconstruction
ne peut pas dire qu'on va monter l'année
prochaine maintenant si on fini premier
au deuxième
on va prendre la place on laissera à
personne ça c'est sûr donc mais c'est
vrai que sur deux trois ans et de
vraiment rebâtir une équipe pour
remonter en deuxième division à savoir
que derrière il faut aussi qu'on assure
au niveau des jeunes
donc là on a un bon groupe u19 on a des
bonus elle a donc menti ni en deuxième
division
d'ici deux trois ans c'est possible on
verra on va tout faire pour en tout cas
vous à mélanie vous y avez goûté à cette
deuxième division est ce que vous avez
envie d'y retourner justement c'est sur
moi je sais que le haut niveau c'est
pour ça que je joue au foot quoi c'est
pour jouer des matchs intensité la
pression on va dire et il ferait tout
pour continuer entre ces niveaux là
merci à vous d'être repassé sur ce
plateau en bon courage pour la suite de
la saison continuera à vous suivre ici
assure tv fil 78 avec les résumés de vos
matches et tous les résultats de chaque
semaine on passe maintenant au basket
retenez bien son nom thomis et gore ce
basketteur eni montant de 19 ans
licencié au club de versailles pourrait
devenir dans les prochaines années le
nouveau tony parker le jeune prodige
vient d'être sélectionnée pour intégrer
pendant un an l'université de cleveland
le montage est signée à romao est fini
je m'appelle pour me senghor j'ai 19 ans
joue à versailles prévu un taux à
cleveland
la carrière de ce basketteur originaire
de montigny le bretonneux et licencié à
versailles vient de prendre un nouveau
tournant
le sportif qui a débuté le basket à 6
ans a tapé dans l'oeil des recruteurs de
l'université de cleveland cet été à los
angeles pendant un camp d'entraînement
organisée par le cibi ciel est une
structure française fondée en 2012 qui
permet des jeunes joueurs de 13 à 22 ans
d'être repérés par les équipes
américaines et ça lui a permis de
rencontrer des coachs américains qui
sont toujours sur place en train de nous
observer en fait sans curé le sage parce
qu'il ne savait pas sur le coup qui
était observé par des coachs pour qu'ils
restent naturelles dans leur jeu et à la
fin du concile certains joueurs
intéressent les coachs ils viennent me
voir pour me le dire et alors là
j'annonce la nouvelle aux joueurs aux
familles ils sont généralement assez
content
je réalisais pas forcément jeu au début
pensé mais non c'est une blague
j'aurais jamais pensé non je ne crois
pas même jusqu'à la semaine dernière je
réalisais pas encore là c'est dans les
derniers jours je me dis là je me dis
c'est demain c'est vrai que je réalise
vraiment jouer l'aventuré américaine a
débuté la semaine dernière pour tommy
lille s'est envolé pour rejoindre ses
nouveaux coéquipiers
aux etats-unis le jour d'un mètre 85 85
kg sont en train draps dans le même
gymnase que lebron james
double champion nba et élu quatre fois
meilleur joueur de la ligue américaine
pour marcher sur les pas de lebron james
tommy devra convaincre l'université le
conservera pendant un an si son essai
concluant le jaune signé mon teint pour
est intégré le circuit professionnel
rapidement les championnats du monde
master de cyclisme sur piste était
programmée la semaine dernière à
manchester l'angleterre
le club de vélizy a brillé pendant la
compétition les yvelinois ont notamment
remporté la médaille d'argent en vitesse
par équipes pour nous parler de cette
performance nous recevons sur ce plateau
ils viennent du jarrier pistard de
vélizy de l'équipe de france est
également consultant cyclisme pour tv
fil 78 5% également sébastien thiéry qui
est du fait partie également du club de
vélizy bonsoir alors ryan tout de suite
on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui a fait la différence sur cette
course vous avez fini deuxième
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence face
aux américains qu'est ce qui pourrait
les américains nous ont battus ben parce
que tout simplement été plus fort que
nous on a beau essayer de réfléchir à
tous et à reposer voilà on était sur
deux postes on était à peu près
équivalent et compte voilà sur un des
postes il y avait et il y avait un gros
écart qui se crée
on n'avait vraiment aucune possibilité
de pouvoir de pouvoir les contrer
maintenant on a en été près on était au
maximum de notre une préparation qui n'a
pas été optimum mais mais voilà on a en
a fait on a fait ce qu'on devait faire
une petite analyse qu'on peut faire
aussi c'est que par rapport à autant qui
a été fait l'année dernière on aurait
aussi eu la deuxième place donc de toute
façon il n'y avait pas ça n'aurait pas
de regrets à avoir par rapport à ça vous
avez la même analyse que yann il était
vraiment trop fort cette année les
américains
oui j'étais fort il n'était pas trop
fort il était battable ils étaient
prenables on était comme dit ian e à
notre niveau on aurait pu être
certainement mieux avec un peu plus de
structuration au niveau d'entraînement
plus d'accompagnement pour réaliser des
montées en puissance plus importante
maintenant il ya des carrés pas très
très significatif
cette 10e c'est pas énorme quand on
compare les deux types de structures de
type d'entraînement qu'on peut avoir
entre eux et nous c'est faible
j'essaie marianne on va en parler ses
entraînements est ce que les américains
seront finalement mieux préparés et
finalement la victoire est logique
c'est logique que ça revienne ils sont
surtout mieux encadré voilà il ya veille
à vis de trois coureurs pour les
américains il avait un entraîneur chose
que ben nous on était trois coureurs
français et on était juste entre nous
dire qu'il y avait il y avait il y avait
il y avait une structure autour d'eux il
y avait une ou des bouts smoothie enfin
on était très motivés tous les trois
mais voilà on était entre nous il ya il
y à un plus que que nous on a pas et ça
ça vient
enfin ça vient du fait que la fédération
ne nous ne nous aident pas on est chacun
dans notre coin à s'entraîner tout seul
on a pas de regroupement eux ils ont
fait des regroupements pour pouvoir
préparer pour pouvoir préparer ces
championnats de cyclisme sur piste au
niveau master et finalement plus
professionnel
aux etats unis c'est ça que vous voulez
dire mais pas que aux états unis en
italie il ya une équipe nationale master
en angleterre il ya aussi des équipes
nationales des équipes nationales
masters c'est pas voilà c'est en france
on est au niveau des masters on est des
amateurs est d'ailleurs sur site de la
fédération si on veut chercher des
résultats dans le masters il faut et
dans le loisir
sauf que pour aller chercher un titre de
champion du monde ou pour aller chercher
un résultat simplement championnat du
monde mais il faut pas s'entraîner comme
un comme un loisir il faut s'entraîner
comme quelqu'un un vrai compétiteur et
est donc on n'a pas tous ses structures
tout c'est sous ce truc ces structures
en france
sébastien vous rejoignez aiai sur ce
point il n'ya pas les structures en
france pour vous accompagner au niveau
master ou qui je le rappelle c'est + 35
ans c'est ça tout à fait enfin 30 ans au
niveau français et 35 ans au niveau
international tout à fait en fait
et ceci malgré le fait qu'il ya des
structures existantes à l'insep à saint
quentin en yvelines à l'insep pour les
juniors les espoirs à saint quentin en
yvelines pour les élites
donc on pourrait tout à fait avoir
possibilité d'intégrer ces structures
en parallèle un bien sûr mais ça serait
tout à fait faisable
maintenant il faut qu'ils n'ouvraient
volonté de la fédération nous
accompagner juste pour rejoinder diane
sur un sur un sujet le vainqueur donc de
l'épreuve sprint cette année catégorie
35 en c1 ou du blé qui est record
maniement de 500 mhz été dit auparavant
et dans ma catégorie et en 40 ans et
énarque x6 qui est vice champion
olympique de kerim donc ça donne le le
niveau de la compétition
sébastien ce qu'il ya quand même du
positif à retenir de cette compétition
on a été vice champion et ça c'est le
plan un petit peu déçu quand même finir
deuxième oui on est déçus parce qu'on
voulait le maillot vraiment et puis on y
allait pour ça maintenant on est vice
champion donc c'est une très belle
il ya peu de gens il ya peu d'élus comme
sur ses podiums internationaux
on a réussi à le faire et puis on a
pleins d'objets plein d'objectifs et
plans de mission pour les années à venir
yann vous allez surfer sur cette
dynamique
cette deuxième place avant on est déjà
en train de réfléchir pour comment faire
en 2016 pour être pour être champion du
monde
on était à peine revenu de on n'était
encore parvenu qu'on était encore à
manchester qu'on essaie déjà de mettre
des solutions de chercher des solutions
pour pour être devant et voilà moi je
n'y a qu'une chose qui me motive dans
dans le sport c'est la victoire donc
donc voilà il ya des petites choses à
des petites choses allaient des petits
détails allez aller combler et on va on
va tout faire pour y arriver
c'est pas possible autrement donc la
prochaine grande compétition ça sera les
championnats du monde nous il y aura
d'autres compétitions il y aura deux
compétitions avant projet voilà on va on
va partir maintenant sur un petit
programme pour pour aller chercher les
championnats de france l'année prochaine
au mois de juin
ou peut-être au mois de mai à bordeaux
on va on va voir et puis il y aura les
championnats d europe aussi qui peut
être auront dû à roubaix cette année et
c'est on va se servir de toutes ces
épreuves pour justement monter l'équipe
qui sera la plus la plus forte pour pour
réussir à remporter ce titre qui nous
qui nous qui nous manque et qui nous
fait tant portant autant envie web merci
à tous et peut être passé sur ce plateau
il ya non retrouvera jeudi prochain pour
la nouvelle émission de tv fils si on
parlait sports jeudi à 19h30
on passe maintenant aux autres résultats
du week-end
je vous en parlais lors du dernier set 8
sport ligne montrent un françois pervis
s'est entraîné toute la semaine dernière
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en vue des
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste une compétition organisée à partir
de ce mercredi jusqu'à ce dimanche à
granges en suisse événement réunira les
plus grandes nations européennes comme
l'angleterre l'allemagne les pays-bas et
bien sûr la france est aidé affiche des
pistards tricolore sera une nouvelle
fois françois pervis pour le sportif
évinois cette compétition n'est pas
forcément une priorité dans sa saison en
écoute les championnats d'europe cette
année c'est juste une étape c'est on va
dire c'est la première étape d'un nombre
incalculable d'autres étapes donc pour
l'instant c'est la toute première donc
on se prend pas la tête
si on est champion d'europe c'est bien
si on ne l'est pas tant pis mais c'est
pas vraiment là dessus que je joue en
sélection pour les jeux olympiques c'est
toujours mieux de montrer qu'on est sûrs
le plus fort donc
gg personnes j'ai aucun nom à donner
c'est plus ou moins en règle générale il
faut simplement montrer qu'on est là on
est bien là et on peut conseiller peut
compter sur nous pour pour être
difficile à battre
course à pied à présent la première
édition des foulées de maurepas était
organisée ce samedi au départ du stade
du bois en faveur de l'association ela
une structure qui lutte contre les
maladies neurodégénératives
trois épreuves étaient au programme une
course de 6 km une course de 12 km et la
marche nordique de 6 km au total plus de
250 participants ont pris le départ de
la course
on écoutait manuel du talent adjoint aux
sports de maurepas il était au micro de
mélanie pop
le but premier n'est pas la compétition
on n'est pas dans un esprit compétitif
bien sûr y aura un classement bien sûr
il ya des il y aura un premier un
deuxième un troisième mais l'idée est
vraiment de participer de s'adonner à
une activité physique
si sur le parcours on veut marcher pour
souffler on le fait l'idée de finir et
de soutenir la cause 2 est là chez les
hommes c'est le jeune valentin oro qui a
remporté le 6 km en 24 minutes et 24
secondes chez les filles la victoire est
revenue à emilie rousset pour le 12 km
nicolas petit j'en termine premier en 44
minutes et 24 secondes pour les dames
géraldine à boussens termina première
toujours en course à pied dit de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines organisée
ce dimanche la 7e édition de l'ekiden un
marathon de 42 km en relais de quatre à
six coureurs dont le classement est
mixte cette année 67 équipes étaient
présentes pour l'événement c'est 20 de
plus que l'année précédente
montrouge a remporté la compétition 2h42
devant l'équipe des tchèques qui a
réalisé un temps de 2h 44 et 19 secondes
le relais de rambouillet complète le
podium le responsable de l'ekiden
frédéric pons nous présente les
particularités de cet événement la
particularité de l'ekiden sais que vous
allez trouver découvrir de très haut
niveau
allez-y à rambouillet
un montrouge qui vont se frotter avait
déjà les copains de quartier une famille
et a par exemple la famille grivel qui
est venu courir donc tout ce milieu de
sportifs se côtoient et il ya une très
bonne ambiance mais c'est un parcours
aussi facile que ça ça secoue un petit
peu quand même il ya de la relance comme
audi dans l'ain terme de la course
mais les coureurs apprécient 1 on
disputait également ce week-end la
course run and bike à plaisir au départ
du domaine du château
la compétition organisée par la ville en
partenariat avec l'association
cyclotouriste plaisir oise combine à la
fois la course à pied et le vélo en
binôme
le concept les deux coéquipiers peuvent
s'échanger le vélo à tour de rôle
le but est de franchir la ligne
d'arrivée en même temps pour les 12 km
c'est le biais le duo torah est bordé du
club d'ici qui a remporté la compétition
en 37 minutes et 38 secondes
une nouvelle discipline était à
l'honneur ce week-end dans le
département la finale nationale 2015 de
football fef port qui mangent comme son
nom l'indiqué le football et le golf
était programmé ce samedi pendant toute
la journée au golf des yvelines nicolas
cousin été sacré à cette occasion
champion de france de la discipline
présentation de ce sport unis qui compte
plus de 3000 adhérents dans l'hexagone
parking vannes est responsable de la
fédération française de golf de football
donc on joue sur un parcours de golf
avec les règles du golf mais les outils
du footballeur c'est à dire donc le
shoot et le ballon dont le principe est
très simple
le but étant de rentrer le ballon dans
un trou qu'on appelle le bogey qui est
adaptée à cet effet en réalisant le
moins de chute possibles pour réaliser
un score le plus proche du parc comme au
golf c'est un sport très conviviale très
accessible aussi également puisque à
l'instar du golfe c'est quand même un
sport où après un défi sportif vous vous
retrouvez directement sur le parcours
donc vous pouvez très rapidement être
très bon faut le golfeur on passe au
handball troisième match et troisième
défaite en nationale 2 masculine pour le
chesnay les joueurs de yanis norbert se
sont inclinés à l'extérieur contre
saintes sur le score de 25 à 21 après
avoir bien débuté la rencontre les
yvelinois se sont effondrés sur la
deuxième mi temps
au classement la situation du chéné est
très préoccupante
le club promu cette année dans cette
division ne compte aucune victoire et a
déjà encaissé 99 buts depuis le début de
la saison
basket à présent trappe n'y arrive
toujours pas en nationale 3 les gens de
mustapha el hafidi ont perdu à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de
barjouville une équipe pourtant à leur
portée
score final 76 à 62 au classement ça se
complique pour trappe les yvelinois
occupe la dernière place du classement
avec trois défaites depuis le début de
la saison on passe à l'agenda du
week-end en basket trappe justement
recevra bons conseils
ce samedi à 20 heures au gymnase paul
mallet la rencontre est déjà très
important dans le calendrier des
trappistes en difficulté en championnat
en championnat après trois défaites et
je me rends compte sur le soutien du
public pour emporter leur vie leur
première victoire de la saison
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78